bonjour françois bayrou bonjour merci
d'être avec nous ce matin sur lci maire
de pau haut commissaire au plan et
président du modem qui en parlera du
cumul des mandats tout à l'heure ça n'a
rien à voir avec vous mais c'est une
question intéressante qui revient sur
d'un paysage gaz électricité maintenant
gazole essence qui flambent des mesures
ont été prises on n'y revient pas la
question ce matin c'est le gouvernement
doit-il faire plus et vite
en tout cas il y pense visiblement c'est
une question qui est posée c'est une
question qui est posée pas depuis ces
derniers semaines mais vous souvenez que
au lancement d'un gilet jaune c'est une
question qui a joué un rôle très
important et notamment la part de taxe
qu'il y a dans le prix du carburant
savez bien que
pourquoi assiste-t-on à cette montée des
prix parce qu'à une flambée du
pétrole du gaz
sur le sur les marchés mondiaux
que la reprise d'un côté le blocage d'un
certain nombre de productions de l'autre
entraînent cette flambée des prix mais
il ya aussi une part de taxe qui est
très sympa très importante de la moitié
mais je veux vous demander françois
bayrou oui le gouvernement est en train
de réfléchir gabriela talent l'a dit
qu'est ce qu'il attend est-ce que
trop tard ça risque pas à nouveau de de
provoquer une crise sociale qu'est ce
qu'il attend le savez bien c'est très
c'est très facile de dire on va dépenser
beaucoup d'argent et c'est nécessaire
pour çà a été nécessaire pour sauver le
pays de l'épidémie pour sauver des
entreprises pour sauver les salariés et
en même temps on va supprimer les
rentrées on va baisser les armes jusqu'à
toutes les taxes et vous savez bien que
il ya là quelque chose qui est
une question sans réponse donc il faut
équilibrer tout ça je suis absolument
certain que si cette situation se
poursuit alors il faudra toucher aux
taxes je n'ai aucun doute et cette
certitude gelé depuis plusieurs années
comme vous ça quel niveau
la tei cpe grandit la taxe intérieure de
consommation sur les produits
énergétiques par exemple celle là qui a
rapporté quand même pardon en france à 0
17 milliards en 2021 de rentrées
supplémentaires
et donc ça on peut la bcc celle là qu'on
peut baisser mais on peut en tout cas
chercher un mécanisme d'adaptation
d'adaptation automatique
à un amortisseur automatique de la
situation incertaine et par oui mais
c'est pas parce qu'on l'a fait une
certaine époque c'était pas l'idée qu'on
puisse reprendre donc un amortisseur ou
un système d'amortissement ou un
mécanisme d'amortissement qui permette
que les ménages se trouve pas totalement
désarmés et vous savez qu'on a décidé le
gouvernement décidé d'aider les millions
de ménages les plus modestes ou ceux qui
ont le plus de difficultés à faire face
aux dépenses courantes de les aider en
leur apportant
tout est un chèque énergie des cheveux
sont des mesures préventives prévention
de hausse la question c'est comment
faire baisser les prix c'est une
question centrale elle préoccupe au
premier plan les français les encore une
fois les mesures gilet jaune elles sont
venues trop tard chèque carburant par
exemple voilà mon temps ciblée est-ce
que ça ce serait une bonne initiative du
gouvernement ben vous allez poser la
question au gouvernement
moi je pense qu'il faut un mécanisme
d'adaptation au mécanisme
d'amortissement sur les sur les taxes et
quand l'opposition accuse le
gouvernement gagner d'argent sur le dos
des français justement en encaissant des
rentrées fiscales supplémentaires grâce
ce type d'accusations elizabeth
martichoux type d'accusation c'est un
c'est le jeu classique le jeu de rôle
classique
hélas trop classique de 2 des
oppositions entre les différentes
factions du pays la sécu ne me suis pas
vous savez bien que
quand ils étaient au pouvoir qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait que vous prenez
exactement la situation cette situation
s'est déjà rencontré qu'est ce qui a été
fait est ce qu'on peut dire que c'était
que c'était efficace et crédible moi je
le crois pas d'ailleurs les français ne
croient pas que faire de gagner de
l'argent sur le donnez vous savez bien
que que ce le gouvernement est un de
ceux qui ont le plus investi pour
sauvegarder la solidité et la solidarité
du pays dans un moment de crise comme on
en n'avait jamais rencontré oui et donc
l'idée que seul que ce soit dans la tête
d'un gouvernement de gagner de l'argent
entre guillemets est une idée qui est
qui accule ridicule qui est ridicule la
cagnotte le gouvernement voudrait
conserver dans ses temps de rentrées
fiscales supplémentaires vont trouver
que c'est ridicule oui encore un mot
quand même sur la baisse des taxes
marine le pen je mettrai fin au racket
fiscal at elle dit au figaro hier elle
propose de faire baisser elle une taxe
la tva de 20 à 5 et demi pour cent vous
achetez vous voyez bien de ce genre de
ce genre d'affirmation là qui sont des
affirmations
pour amuser le tapis
solide parce que marine le pen dans le
même temps elle demande qu'on dépense
beaucoup plus sur tous les postes de
dépenses il n'est pas crédible de tenir
les deux affirmations en même temps ce
sont des propos électoraux qui vise
simplement à gagner la faveur
des électeurs ou des futurs électeurs
pendant la période que la version rien
de sérieux là dedans tant qu'on ne on
aura pas en tête que les immenses
investissements qui ont été faits et les
immenses investissements qu'il va
falloir faire par exemple si on veut que
l'énergie soit moins cher alors il faut
qu'on fasse des investissements en
matière énergétique
en matière de production de l'énergie de
l'électricité en particulier
qui sont réellement impressionnant est
réellement nécessaire parce que sans ça
on n'y arrivera pas regardez le il y
avait sur votre antenne il ya cinq
minutes il y avait un sujet sur
l'électrification des voitures les
voitures propres tout le monde y toutes
les organisations qui s'intéressent au
climat 10 il faut que la plupart des
usages qui sont aujourd'hui par des
hydrocarbures de l'essence du pétrole et
du gaz on va on va les remplacer
l'électricité consommer de plus en plus
électrisant bien ça fait d'électricité
en plus moi je pense plus de 50 % de
consommation d'électricité et donc il
faut se doter de moyens de la produire
et il faut se doter de moyens de la
produire qui ne polluent pas parce que
c'est notre engagement n'est ce pas vous
en avez rendu compte 1000 voix sur votre
plateau on a dit nous la france on
s'inscrit dans l'accord de paris c'est à
dire l'engagement international que on
produira nous ne pourrons nous ne nous
ne produirons plus de gaz à effet de
serre et quel est le seul moyen si on ne
veut pas produire de gaz à effet de
serre faut faire du renouvelable mais en
même temps il faut équilibrer le
renouvelable parce qu'il n'y a pas de
vent et de soleil tout le temps et il ya
des inconvénients aussi part de la
production d'électricité nucléaire et
ses essais ce sens de l'année sur mini
centrales nucléaires pas se lancer et
vous vraiment que vous dites françois
bayrou il va aussi falloir falloir
investir sur des nouvelles centrales
père en france en plus de flamanville
mais vous voyez bien nous avons par
chance un parc de production
d'électricité nucléaire qui fait écouter
bien que nous sommes le pays du monde du
monde le plus nucléarisé si on en dire
le produit le nucléaire pas du tout
facile quand on est champion d'automne
aux abeilles on peut pas dire les choses
comme ça nous sommes le pays du monde
qui produit le mois qui émet le moins de
gaz à effet de serre gras sans nucléaire
située dans lequel on est en
échantillons et dante est donc cette
cette question là va entraîner des
décisions qui sont des décisions qui
vont être prises elles doivent être
prises dans les deux ans qui viennent
ce nîmes en ce débat une immense
question autrement je vous dis ça et eve
est dans la campagne présidentielle bien
évidemment vous le sentez comment je
vous dis ça nous ne pourrons pas remplir
en aucune manière les engagements que
nous avons pris la main sur le coeur en
disant que nous ne produisons pas de
gaza je serai juste que vous me
répondiez une question précise vous
devenez de faire le plaidoyer précise
parce que il un peu floue emmanuel
macron sur cette question il a dit oui
on va on va en reparler est ce que dans
sa campagne est ce que macron candidats
il doit annoncer des nouveaux chantiers
de faire en france oui ou non non ne
d'essayer pas de l'enfermer dans des oui
ou non là je vais vous répondre
clairement brièvement le président le
président de la république dit 1 je vais
soutenir l'effort de recherche
pour mettre au point des ministres
et deuxièmement il faudra prendre
d'autres décisions dans les mois qui
viennent c'est son sais pas si ça fera
un terme à sa phrase et vous voyez bien
qu'il a donc ça en tête et que je n'ai
pas de doute que le débat de l'élection
présidentielle quels que soient les
candidats juin entend de michèle bernier
à l'instant ils disent sans nucléaire on
peut pas y arriver
ce sera un débat d'après d'un ciel mais
vous ne voulez pas dire s'il devra dans
son discours de candidat fret ayant fait
un candidat à l'élection présidentielle
je puis vous assurer qu'il n'ya que le
candidat qui puisse elle même alors sus
des réponses justement à propos de la
nécessité d'avoir des comptes publics
quand même
équilibre est le plus possible malgré
les dépenses j'ai une question à vous
poser la réforme des retraites pourquoi
la majorité ou l'elysée entretiennent
t-il l'idée d'une réforme des retraites
ça continue là où s'il ya un flou alors
qu'elle ne se fera pas avoir le jeu je
n'ai pas entendu le président de la
république dire ça je sais que c'est une
question que l'ensemble des responsables
du gouvernement a à l'esprit on aura
besoin d'une réforme
pourquoi est ce que cette idée continue
si je puis dire d'être entretenue par
une partie de la majorité par des
enfants je ne sais pas qui c'est ça la
magie est ce que vous êtes d'accord pour
dire que ça ne peut pas se faire avant
la moi je vois qu'il ne peut pas y avoir
qu il faut mais quand vous dites une
partie de la majorité dit que je ne sais
pas qui est une partie avait critiqué
hier édouard philippin pour la création
de son parti on reviendra peut-être
bombe en tout cas edouard philippe il a
dit celui sur raisonnable aller à 65 66
67 ans pour l'âge légal de la retraite
mais voyez 5 cette phrase là dans
challenges elles alimentent l'idée qu'
il faut le faire le plus vite possible
mais vous savez bien que le
cette idée de la retraite à 67 ans qui a
été popularisé par vous en particulier
parpaings par les médias et par ses
interviews de challenges j'avais cette
idée ne me paraît pas une idée
en phase
avec ce qu'est la société française et
le modèle social français
il y à des professions qui sont des
professions qui usent ce qu'ils les
remplissent un rippeur dans la rue vous
savez de ce ceux qui chargent les
poubelles vous allez lui dire que il
faut qu'il reste jusqu'à 67 ans les gens
qui sont dans le bâtiment les ouvreurs
je prends la lèvre des charges ce qui
lève des chats non
cette idée que le recul de l'âge de la
retraite jusqu'à 67 ans est une idée qui
je crois risque de heurter et c'est
papa toxiques mais en tout cas c'est eu
en tout cas c'est une idée comme moi je
ne partage pas le
je suis maire de pau comme vous avez eu
la gentillesse de le rappeler je vois ce
qu'est au ccas enfin
au centre communal d'action sociale le
travail des femmes se sont le plus
souvent des femmes qui vont s'occuper
des personnes âgées sentence est là
reste importante et soit moi je ne peux
pas dire à quelqu'un qui est usée qui a
des problèmes de dos à 50 ans vous irait
jusqu'à 67 ans et part c'est pas
possible et enfin dernier point
c'est une vue de l'esprit parce que la
plupart de ceux qui seraient concernés
par une éventuelle mesure ils sont au
chômage donc on transfère et vous savez
bien que les entreprises à partir d'un
certain âge 19 ans vous êtes un peu trop
page et je peux pas vous embaucher et
donc le 1 on a des engagements sociaux
qui sont justes et 2 on a apposé le
problème dans l'autre sens c'est comment
créer suffisamment d'emplois pour que
les caisses de retraite soit équilibrée
alors on va avancer à beyrouth je
voudrais quand même revenir sur votre
votre critique me dit tu peux pas
critiquer si j'ai bien entendu hier vous
avez dit que la création du parti des
verts philippe on ne crée pas un parti
politique autour d'une personnalité j'ai
une vision plus profondes voilà je vous
avais dit j'ai une vision plus profondes
ma question à les différentes un parti
politique est ce que c est ce que ce
type de déclaration qui peut être
interprétée comme une critique elle gêne
à la hauteur je sais ce que c'est à la
hauteur du moment françois berger dit
nous avons telle affluence oui des
différences et en particulier parce que
toute la tradition politique dans
laquelle je m'inscris c'est une
tradition politique des grands courants
du pays il ya un grand courant
socialiste il ya un grand courant
communiste d'extrême gauche ya un grand
courant écologiste depuis plusieurs
décennies il ya un grand courant de
droite va pas refaire l'histoire mais il
ya des nuances c'est vrai mais vous ya
des nuances et
je vous avais dit plus profondes quand
même j'ai une vision plus profondes non
ma vision des partis politiques c'est
des courants profonds du pays et ceci
c'est les courants profonds c'est pas
votre vie si vous avez écouté si vous
écoutez j'ai toujours défendu la même
idée pour la raison simple que moi je
suis engagé dans le courant qui est le
mien depuis l'âge de 20 ans mais tous
ceux qui veulent soutenir le président
de la république sont bienvenus tous
ceux qui veulent apporter leur pierre
comme on dit à cet édifice sont
bienvenues d'accord et le welcome
edouard philippe évidemment qui a dit sa
loyauté à l'égard de legendary public
d'ailleurs vous êtes maire de pau
j'aimerais savoir comment vous auriez
réagi françois bayrou si un de vos
adjoints à la mairie de pau avait
déclaré que le but de la police est de
protéger la population il n'est pas de
posséder des armes pour l'art tuer c'est
un adjoint de cachan la france insoumise
qui a sous entendu que la police peut
avoir pour but de tuer la population
ce n'importe quoi c'est de ces c'est
affligeant
les stupides on peut pas dire autre
chose donc faut pas se perdre à un
commentaire c'est ça le losc épine basse
et infligeant c'est offensant c'est
irrespectueux et c'est faux oui c'est
quoi votre avis c'est un dérapage à de
l'électoralisme
c'est un relâchement dans le débat
associés policiers assassins je sais pas
qui est ce qui suppose un adjoint au
maire de cachan la france a soumis ce
qui n'a pas désavoué son histoire prouve
qu'il peut y avoir des adjoints qui
disent des énormités les énormités et
offenses enfin papa des énormités sans
conséquence yahia cette radicalité qui
peut être formulée enfin si on l'a jugée
en tout cas radical à gauche du paysage
politique à zemmour et moi il est à 14 %
dans un sondage bébé est un candidat
sérieux
oui à ce niveau de sondage ce sont des
candidats qui réunissent beaucoup de
voix est-ce que c'est des thèses auquel
on rend toi
en raison des scores dans les sondages
auxquels on doit accorder du crédit moi
pas oui mais il est à 14 % ça veut dire
qu'il ya déjà une partie de la pop n'est
pas encore candidat
il me partie de la population qui jugent
sa sérieux ça dit quoi et pourquoi ça se
passe sous le mandat de d'emmanuel
macron qu'est-ce qu'il a ratée pour que
toutes ces radicalité se manifeste
maintenant accusé par ailleurs vous
connaissez suffisamment l'histoire
électorale de la france
jean-marie le pen a été au deuxième tour
en quelle année
1 vous souvenez s'il ya vingt ans
et se rappeler avec quel score avec ses
6 ans nation on additionne marine le pen
eric zemmour ça fait bien plus encore
que jean marie le pen qualifier au
deuxième tour mais que d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce que je scanne par l'asa peu ce
que ça peut arriver là tout en avril
2022 mais bien sûr mais ça peut arriver
à tout instant annuel macro zhimin ça
peut très bien arriver le on est une
société c'est même le diagnostic a été
celui du président de la république
quand il s'est présenté au début une une
société qui est profondément déstabilisé
ne l'a pas il ne l'a par stabiliser à 4
quand viendra quand on a fait comme vous
la chronique des crises successives
depuis les gilet jaune jusqu'à
l'épidémie qui se sont succédé
dans l'histoire de ces cinq années on a
au moins un minimum de commande urgences
n'ont pas d'indulgence de crédit à faire
au fait qu'il a fallu résister à ces
crises et résistait bien de manière vous
connaissez la situation aujourd'hui y
compris pour le pouvoir d'achat des gens
compris des progression du pouvoir
d'achat
oui et y compris des professions du
pouvoir d'achat des 10% les mois les
moins riches de la france donc quand on
a eu des crises comme ça c'est normal
que c'est normal qu'on fasse qu'on fasse
là c'est une société profondément
déstabilisée elle n'est pas profondément
déstabilisé seulement en france elle est
déstabilisé sur la planète est en tout
cas dans l'occident tout entier cette
société elle s'inquiète pour son
identité et ça c'est un droit de dés des
peuples et des sociétés de s'inquiéter
pour l'identité la transmission le fait
que demain ressemblera un peu à ce que
nous avons connu aujourd'hui c'est un
droit mais ce qui n'est pas normal et
légitime c'est d'en faire un sujet
d'affrontement des français entre
d'affrontement des femmes des hommes et
des enfants d'autant plus un droit que
la question n'ont pas été
fondamentalement réglée par les pouvoirs
successifs mais compris celui des
ménages en vous disant secret non oui
quand jamais les pouvoirs ne règlent
totalement les questions d sociale bat
ça vous allez on compte alimenter les
abstentionnistes ou non à la peine de
magalas on peut progrès non mais vous
vous savez bien l'atlantique vous vous
savez bien que vous faites une
présentation qui est elle à préciser
votre pensée faux ratures excessive non
c'est le l'épreuve lorsque les sociétés
rencontrent des moments aussi
déséquilibré déstabiliser que celle que
nous connaissons personne ne règle d'un
coup de baguette magique ça n'existe pas
mais on peut progresser en compréhension
mutuelle en
envie de construire quelque chose qui
ressemble un peu à un idéal que l'on
porte et si on fait ça alors on est à la
hauteur de l'engagement civique merci
françois bayrou d'avoir été ce matin sur
le plateau de lci bonne journée à vous